Nag 3
Hayeom Swallow to roar in color Haenam Overseas
Bath Pad Tak Bob Lifestyle
tools Timing is May
Dalt Woah It's a
real love
What I thought about what the cost What was the cost
It was when we were recording now,
but it's
called Livelihood Day. Now Jinyoung hyung is on the
road, so you saw an error that caused a disease
As time goes by, I
can feel that way too I hope it will be like that
fls cell waters
Let me think about it for a bit But this shot you, you and me, you were
Scarlett Johansson
Just watching a movie, ah, it’s
more than a real description, and
it feels like I’m attaching something so new
Also, looking at him, that's what's
called charm. It
must be trouble
There are a lot of
songs that aren't social. We know each other a little bit. We're
still in our fans. But before the price, there was one thing we
did first.
Homer. Hwang said something rough.
Anyway, I'll get up in the morning and take a
shower. What should I say these days? I wake up in the
morning and have the simple feeling of part 2 like
this, sitting in front of the chip like this,
it's really
sagging  And from then on, at home, it's
nothing wrong, and I go out and wear clothes for going out in
advance. France
tickets would be elementary school if that's the case.
I don't know why I did that while I was trying to watch a kissing assistant at the time I had a mate,
but I think it's a gun.
Amber Essay Mun Ste Right now, ah,
honestly, this is what the eaves of a devastating fall will look at,
but I got over it, but the
shame I remember right now is the embarrassment that I remember right now,
we were on a world
tour.
You do the ending while playing, too,
while you were doing something, you sprinkled water
on it, but it slipped like this and
it slipped like this  When it happens
,
I really cry inside, how can everyone be a
little
careful? A little bit of this, I thought about
it a
lot  Yes, she
was really cute, but
these days, seeing how she has grown so much
, I just saw her and now she was doing solo activities
.  I saw it when I was too young, so
what is it now? It’s just that the
youngest members were the first to do promotions. So just watching that
, I felt something proud
.  By the way,
when I went to see the Youngjae musical, the brothers were
real when I saw the warrant for the first time
.
I need to
explain.
The kids are
getting it, but now I’m doing so well, so I’m
proud of it. W I feel like I’m about to cry.
And in Jinyoung’s case, at
first, I wondered how
I could work so hard, so I got a little
inspired, more stimulated
, something harder, something harder with each other.
I think it was a partner who had good synergy to do this. It’s true that the hat of writing a book
is true. I went and said the tabernacle
when I first came, so I was embarrassed and
yes,
but Jackson also just
seems to have aged in ancient
times.
Also, I'm not very good with shooting skills, so I
thought a lot
that I had to watch parts like having a server and then get a seal again, and there's something strange
about the park.
Because I know, we had
to fight in the practice room back then
.
I was separated from my family and I was standing alone and pulling everything but I thought how difficult it would be
,
so I felt sorry
.
Everyone had feelings about this kind of anxiety that it might not work
So now, I
think I said something like
that.  I can't
do it, we've already been together like this for this much, but I remember saying things like, "I'll fight if there's only
one person left,
or if I can't
, I'll fight
."  Oh, come on,
and if you talk like this,
you can write a little bit less, but now I took a
dream high toe for a while, and now I
have a day off, so I went to my daily life with it.
I don't know. I heard it. It
's not fun to use it all of a sudden. It's not fun. It's
just like this. Yes, it's
like this. 5 Oh,
so it's slightly clean
.
I just didn't know the time, so I just
admit it. What should I do?
But I was just expecting this kind of spirit
. Suddenly, the person next to
me is ya-ya-no-ga. Is this plan going crazy
? Because someone else's other person is
talking about it in the look, I'm
ready to go.
I saw it and it was just
amazing A little uh me I was
really in school, and always
just like my life as a student was always
just a little bit normal.
But these days,
I think it’s good. It’s
fun and
I can talk to a lot of different things, so I can hear a lot of different things,
so I’m in the
4th
press, so I’m in our
state.
I feel a lot of dreams. It was my first time acting while the writers were shooting mite. I
learned to learn the chill,
but I did not learn it professionally, but I actually did all
acting at that company.
I learned acting because I thought that this song would be helpful if my sensitivity increased, but
while watching Dream High Tool like this,
while filming Athens, I feel that I am
lacking a lot
.  I think he gave me a lot of advice like this, but
I don't know who
's driving it, but it must have happened again. I can just sit down in the field with Seojun hyung and me.
I think it would be better to read this part like this while reading the script.
The scene between me and Seo Jun-young of the two
we talked about comes to mind a lot and it bulges out. So if you write it down, I
'll be grateful for the video.
After I spelled it, I
think it was my parents
.
Unless you're a student
, there are a lot of people who are a little cautious when their parents are a little bit shy when they're students
.
I want to do it and go to my parents
. We're having dinner and we're just going to
dance without studying. At that time, I
actually thought what my son would hear about this, but
it's
so greener than you think. Do
what you want
to do.  Ha No
, I think I told you something like this at
that time. I get it at that time, but as
time goes by, I am more grateful for it, and
my parents had such a choice
.
Oh, but I want to talk about the person who made me the second time, but
Jinyoung doesn't have a
hyung.
Please, p-hyung 2
I just worked hard on GOT7's
song and how I came to be, I
have to prove it with this. What I can do
I think I can do it a little easier
. And it's not that doing that music
doesn't help me, and
it can also become my d-velody,
so I worked really hard at that time.
But as things went well
and the level of Wan increased a lot,
Jinyoung hyung said something like that.
So I had a meeting like this
. Now, Mocha Seven Go. The
close mother will take
care of it, so I said that I wouldn't do it well.
I've heard it before
, but it's strangely my parents don't feel like I've been recognized
Oh,
I've been trying to prove it before, it's
1st
P lsc doll Bum Reason Abbey
Unexpected 5
You might think that this person wrote a cg, but
my first
cg season album was  I bought Damian Rice's
Volcano all album for the
first time
There are artists who just link songs like this on a CD like this
. I think it's very attractive, so
we still buy our cgs and buy the ones we
want to hear
.
Anna Lee
Now performed on a scale of 13,000 people when
they didn't show up, but I didn't know that so many people would come, and what was even more surprising during the performance was that so
many people listen to our
song and
don't just do it and dance together sometimes
.  I just
stood on the stage like this, and looking at it like this, that person will
not see me either.
Yes,
uh, that came up very fresh,
not pen service, but Pen s Pen’s service.
Fan’s attitude. Like Kobe
. Something like this. It can be this good. Oh, or style.
If you're sleeping and your
cat allergy gets a little worse,
there are times when you see it getting worse, and there are times when
we sleep with it. Then
we played a long time ago, when I was a baby
.  I see insults when I look at everything like this
. It seems like I’m leaving it like this.
So,
I
think that was the first time
I thought that I was the person in charge of
him.  No one is true Cap Pulse,
but in
Korea, they call me a butler now, so what I
thought was a butler buna I'm just playing with a fishing rod,
I'm so excited. I'm
just
playing with value because I
'm having fun.
pls pls ten
There was no such thing as a bit of control I didn't have any sandals like
rock music that came and did just that
I think I talked about a
lot of new things by
my standards.
uh
[music
] uh